ce smartphone a une caméra thermique
d'une portée de 1 km c'est pas un
smartphone que vous allez avoir vous
pour aller vous balader regardez jusqu'à
1 km et pour voir s'il y a de la chaleur
c'est vraiment plus intéressant pour des
secours des secours en montagne on se
parle ici d'un très gros bloc on est à
plus de 400 grammes le téléphone c'est
un smartphone résistance et les
smartphones c'est pour là où dort
imagine des pompiers en montagne on peut
imaginer différents corps de métiers qui
pourraient avoir besoin de cette
technologie vous allez avoir une lumière
à l'extérieur pour venir allumer voir un
peu sur le dernier maître ce qui se
passe vous avez un gros haut-parleur ici
extrêmement puissant pour pouvoir
communiquer pour pouvoir envoyer du son
pour pouvoir alerter si besoin et vous
avez en plus un bouton qui est
totalement personnalisable sur le côté
qui vous servira pour venir déclencher
la lampe lorsque vous voulez pas
conserver une prise jack qui va être
planqué en dessous aussi je trouve ça
assez marrant et puis pour avoir une
caméra thermique qui va fonctionner bien
évidemment en vision nocturne c'est
extrêmement pratique la boîte c'est AGM
c'est une boîte chinoise qui vous
présente ce nouveau smartphone le G2
voir dernière alors je sais pas si vous
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
vraiment un intérêt est-ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressant d'ailleurs ce que
je joue dans votre vie ce système de
caméra thermique aurait pu vous sauver
la vie marquez moi ça bien évidemment
dans les commentaires